على وقع رنين الاجهزه يتشبثون بالحياه
يقطعون مسافات كبيره بين المدن للخضوع
لجلسات الغسيل لكن حياتهم هنا تبقى مرهونه
بتوفير مواد وادويه اوشكت على النفاذ لولا
تدخل اغاثي عاجل لمركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
والسؤال عندي سؤال زياده قالوا لازم ثلاث
غسالات اضافيه
المركز
اولا من ناحيه الزحام وثانيا من ناحيه
المواد المواد الموجوده لدينا والمخزنه
لدينا
الخاصه بمرضى الفشل الكلوي اوشكت على
النفاذ حيث لما تبقى لدينا الا ما يغطي
عشر ايام فقط لا غير
ناشدنا الكثير وبعثنا
بعده مذكرات للوزاره
والمدير المكتب الصحه والسلطه المحليه في
المحافظات هنا التدخل للمركز اذا ينقض
حياه اكثر من 450 مصابا بالفشل الكلوي في
تعز بمعدل 2500 جلسه غسيل اذ عمل المركز
هذه المره على رفض ثلاثه مستشفيات في
المدينه بمواد غسيل للتخفيف من معاناه
نستعد لاستقبال المرحله الثالثه وكذلك
المرحله الرابعه وهكذا لان مركز الكلى
الصناعيه اصبح جزء لا يتجزا من الدعم
الاصيل والمتواصل لمركز الملك سلمان
للغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه المركز الملك
سلمان ليس الاول مره وانما يدعم بالكثير
انما يزود المستشفيات على مستوى القطاع
الصحيح وايضا مراكز اخرى بادويه مستلزمات
مشكورين مشكورين وهذا ايضا اغاثه من
اخواننا في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
طبعا الملك وايضا الحكم وشعبا والسعوديه
بشكل عام كل يوم على هذا الحال تمتلئ
الاسره هذه بمرضى الفشل الكلوي ويخضع اكثر
من 880 مريضا لجلسات الغسيل يوميا في
القسم هذا لكن ما يهدد هذا القسم بالاغلاق
نفاذ ماده البنزين الى جانب شح المواد
الطبيه
اكثر من 450 مصاب بالفشل الكلوي في تعز
يهدد الحرب والحصار حياتهم كل يوم الى
جانب نفادي الادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه
ومحاليل غسيل الكلى من المراكز هذه الخاصه
بعمليه الغسيل هل سعيد العربيه
تعز لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات